and Jim Nantz now a CBS colleague of
this man who deserves every last bit of
congratulations on his new deal with CBS
Sports after yeoman's work in the booth
with kevin burkhart for so many years
number 2 cruel on fox one of our great
friends charles davis how are you CD
I'm doing great rich thanks a lot I
appreciate it very very much trust you
too family still healthy xavius and i
hope everyone who can hear our voices
saying yes thank goodness we're all
healthy and well and that does include
my children coming into my office
several times during last night's for
our broadcast of this schedule because
that's where the iPads were being
charged but thankfully there was you
know they snuck in snuck out I was able
to conduct my appointed rounds
so you don't you have no idea what your
games are right I mean I know that
that's a crazy question but okay so but
I'm I'm wondering what your your first
blush thoughts of that week one schedule
I just kind of broke it all down what
what leaps out to you Charles well
immediately you know we knew obviously
what Kansas City would be doing in terms
of hosting who day we get well that
wasn't a major surprise but I think
everyone's locked in on Sunday night New
Orleans and Tampa I mean it's hard to
get past that is that's gonna be great
but I mean right out of the gate we
wondered what it would be we know would
be one of the crimes right I mean uh you
knew Brady would being one of them but
would it be Monday night Sunday night we
knew it wasn't gonna be Thursday so what
that one just jumped right out at me
right out of the gate we just thought
okay make sense alright this is
fantastic
let's move this bad boy along and then
you just kind of as you go through the
schedule you can't help but look at
quarterback matchups but I have one that
I found interesting early deep deep into
the schedule rich in December a playoff
team that is trying its best to make
that last step thought they were going
to a couple of years ago didn't get
there
soiled again last year in the divisional
round Minnesota Viking and member
her cousin was supposed to be the guy
that put him over the top
well here's Tampa Bay getting Brady
Glock having a good draft great
offseason they're trying to go
essentially from worst to first to
compete for a Super Bowl of their home
stadium that's a game in December
playoff being non playoff team although
you don't suspect that the Tampa Bay
will be that that one looks like fun the
Kirk Cousins were supposed to be the
difference and here you got a chance
going at the CP 12 I have you know she's
games like that the fascinate me rich
charles davis here on the Rich Eisen
show and how about the Buffalo Bills man
I know you'll be calling a few of those
games now with CBS the Bills have not
one not two not three but four
nationally televised appearances and
they they earned it man I mean they went
into Dallas and spanked him on
Thanksgiving they went into Houston and
shouldn't won that playoff game they've
got you know they've got some guys that
are gonna be winding up on your fantasy
team as opposed to previous years how
good do you think the bills can be
Charles I think they can be very good I
think for the bills their biggest hurdle
truthfully rich in my mind it just the
specter of New England because they will
go into the season as the favorite in
the AFC and what was the last time we
said anyone was the favored AFC's
other than New England yeah like even
the years know England didn't win it
outright they tied for it and remember
we had that crazy quirky year where they
won 11 and five with Matt Cassel after
TP 12 got hurt and Game one at Kansas
City and didn't make the playoffs I
think you know just one of those weird
season could be something like that
would happen at 11 and 5 so for Buffalo
the good thing they've got going for
them it ain't like New England really
talked I mean that's not been an easy
one look last year Buffalo is probably
right on NFL Network there if I remember
correctly which that Saturday yep if
Josh Allen does an airmail bout throw -
Dawson Oxley the game gets off my gosh
you know right there so to me it's the
specter of knowing when for Buffalo more
than anything else I think this is a
team that's still on
Rhys Josh Allen I'll guarantee you he's
putting work in in the off season even
though we're all limited because of the
pandemic that's out there another team
to that you'll be seeing more often than
not that I'm fascinated by is Denver
nobody's gonna you know what I mean like
they're gonna be flying under the radar
we're gonna be talking about the
defending Super Bowl champs we're gonna
be talking about is Justin Herbert
taking over for the Chargers we're
absolutely gonna be talking about the
Raiders for good reason but nobody is
gonna be talking about the Broncos whose
offense if Locke can show up in the
manner in which he was beginning to show
up at the end of last year they can make
some hay with Fangio tightening the
bolts on the defense as the HC Charles
when you say and you know yeah you know
what else they got Goodrich it's easy on
offense to say okay you've added Melvin
Gordon to Philip Lindsay in the
backfield check you've added at the
tight end position in the draft
Alberto going in there with no offense
obviously Judy and hammerheads the
receiving corps but they got better in
the interior Graham Glasgow coming from
Detroit right now stencil him to be the
starting center but then they drafted
Lloyd cushion berry out of LSU who I
think is a natural starting center and
glassed out there great experience
playing guard either way I expect both
of them to be in the lineup
whichever configuration they want and
now you got better in part of your
quarterback and what drives it going
back craziest in the NFL got pressure
those two will help tamp that down you
know I think they made a lot of good
news in the offseason okay I know we're
just went a little bit under the radar
here what do you what do you think of
the Colts and Philip Rivers did you by
the way hear about Philips announcement
today Charles that was like a Family
Feud moment five answers on the board
here's your question Philip ravers made
this big announcement today you just
buzzed in with baby do you have do you
have the buzzer [ __ ] do you have the
buzzer
show me sure you do have the buzzer
I'm sorry I'll get it show me baby no
wow no he announced he announced that he
is going to be Wow that is fantastic
number 10 he is that he is the next
button that not on the book well on the
Philip Rivers board top 10 answer's no
he is going to be taking over the head
coach of the high school football
program at Saint Michael Catholic in
Fairhope Alabama when he's done playing
he's absolutely doing it because he did
say that but you know obviously his
father was a coach and Phillip you know
the famous story of him throwing the
football in that motion coming from the
big football right the whole deal and
and here he is following a dead
footsteps and he didn't mention that
about his kid being that age and wanting
to coach them he's actually doing and
obviously look the broadcast that he did
was out there for him if he wanted it
went plenty of people were in play for
him but he's gonna follow his heart and
go ahead and do the coaching now the
crazy part is you know Dave Logan of the
Denver you know Dave does the Broncos
radio and has for years they stayed as a
coach of high school football while
doing the Broncos radio well bit
different the network TV because of
timing sure but he did that for years
and by the way want a ton of state
championships up there they were very
good congratulations it's no looker
maybe extra congratulations to know this
is Rivers that there's not babies never
again but I don't think Phil a lot of
people talking about Phillip long one
year deal one and done in Indianapolis I
know they pick Jacob Eason but uh I
don't see Eason is this starting
quarterback there in 2021 I see Phillip
maybe sticking around here certainly if
he wins and gets to a Super Bowl gets
close to if he plays at eye-level Chris
Ballard and Frank Reich will be bringing
another contract to him and I expect so
up to want to play he loves playing
football don't think over being high
school coach when the time's right but
he feels don't feel that he's playing at
that Philip Rivers level which was just
two years ago was a pretty darn good
level yeah I could see that I'm with you
on that one Jacob Ethan I don't think
he's like a super threat
right away Jacob Eason we'll find out
about him rich if there seems it really
goes awry which I don't expect it to do
in Indianapolis I expect them to be very
good all right now I've got two minutes
left with you Charles so who is the
favorite in the in the AFC is it the
defending champions world champion
Chiefs and I I don't ask that question
with any disrespect normally you do you
do have to put those defending Super
Bowl champions atop a conference that
they that they won but the Ravens did
finish is the 1 seed last year and the
Chiefs and the Ravens never faced each
other in the playoffs thanks to Derek
Henry and Ryan Tannehill and the Titans
who do you who do you install as the
favorites to win the conference that
you'll be covering the most on CBS
I do install Kansas City because it
feels like a college return 20 of 22
starters and rich unfortunately because
of the pandemic it never really got
tested in terms of resolving the
offseason you know what it's like for
Super Bowl champs right everyone's doing
commercials TV shows you know radio
shows although the whole deal they
haven't had to really do that it's been
a quiet one so they are the favorites
wall car has unfinished business
obviously and they get way better in the
offseason free agency and in the in the
draft
don't don't overlook Tennessee they say
it out to the world we're gonna play
Tennessee football aren't we by draft
and Isaiah was the first round right
tackle from Georgia so it's gonna be fun
to see and well Mike Ravens got the best
swiss watch guard that we've ever seen
during the draft sit by his desk so he's
good to go
this that was Kingsbury called it the
circus when we had him on talking about
his his beautiful bond it'll hang out
you know draft set up but oh my god yeah
Barry won I mean let's face it he won no
matter what the best for me was seeing
him there and you know everyone had all
the accouterments around him even be a
he may have had was the glass of wine
out if he had the computers and sitting
out on the deck and of course doing it
very bah-bah right class was chilling I
didn't see a computer I didn't see a
homer rested I stopped their class I got
this under control
folks I'm winning because it was it was
all out in the Cabana that's why
you know hey Charles congrats Congrats
on your new gig brother your you rolling
sir yeah and let me know when you get
your when you get your new blazer with
the CBS logo on it take a picture I want
to see it I still have my blazer right
here in the closet of the Rich Eisen
show green room I still have mine from
the US Open years ago I love that I have
I have my original CBS Sports blazer
when I was doing sidelines an NCAA
tournament back in the closet I've
always been afraid to take it down and
try it on it's still face your stuff
you're still the same slender man you're
a fine wine thanks for the call Charles
you gotta that's Charles Davis hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here